just in general critical thinking is
good the best thing you can do is teach
people to write because there's no
difference between now and thinking rise
and shine it's expresso time what's up
elimination it's Evan I believe in you
and this channel is designed to be a
part of your daily success routine so
let's start your day off right together
grab your tea and sip on today's message
think critically over to you Elon Musk
also if you want to know what Elon Musk
and other successful entrepreneurs have
to say about building unstoppable
confidence check out my 250 for
confidence series where every day for
the next 254 days I will send you a
morning video for free to help you build
your confidence the link to join is in
the description below yeah there are
times when something is important enough
you believe it enough that you do you do
it in spite of fear this advice I forgot
I think the you know the physics
training is a very good training where
it's a good framework for reasoning we
you're trained to think about first
principles and reason from there and
that means boiling things down to the
most fundamental truths and then
connecting those truths in a way to try
to understand how reality is because you
know physics has this problem where
they're trying to figure out things that
are totally counterintuitive and so they
had to have a framework for forgetting
they're like quantum mechanics is
incredibly counterintuitive but it's
true
and so you had so the physics developed
a framework for for figuring out things
that aren't obvious and that's why I
think it's it's it's a lot of advice but
it's it's it's the right framework if
just in general critical thinking is
good you know examining whether you have
the correct axioms are the most
applicable axioms does the logic
necessarily connect and then what are
the range of probable outcomes outcomes
are usually not deterministic they're
there they're a range and so you want to
figure out what those probabilities are
and make sure ideally that you or the
house it's fine to gamble as long as
you're the house yes it's up so that is
is to listen to critical feedback which
we alluded to earlier voice oolitic
solicit critical feedback particularly
from friends because generally they will
be thinking it but they won't tell you
the best thing you can do is teach
people to write because there's no
difference between that and thinking and
one of the things that just blows me
away about universities is that no one
ever tells students why they should
write something it's like well you have
to do this assignment well why are you
writing well you need the great it's
like no you need to learn to think
because thinking makes you act
effectively in the world thinking makes
you win the battles you undertake and
those could be battles for good things
if you can think and speak and write you
are absolutely deadly nothing can get in
your way so that's why you learn to
write it's like when I can't believe
that people aren't just told that it's
it's it's like it's the most powerful
weapon you can possibly provide someone
with and I mean I know lots of people
who have been staggeringly successful
and watched them throughout my life I
mean those people you don't want to have
an argument with them they'll just slash
you into pieces
and they're not in a malevolent way it's
like if you're gonna make your point and
they're gonna make their point you
better have your points organized
because otherwise you are gonna look
like and be an absolute idiot you are
not gonna get anywhere and if you can
formulate your arguments coherently and
make a presentation if you can speak to
people
if you can lay out a proposal god people
give you money they give you
opportunities you have influence let's
talk about what you know again average
versus phenomenal when people who are
met with opposition what do you what do
you do what do you do with your average
and what do you do with your phenomenal
I think of your average you play into
the situation you know I just had so
like let's say it's perceived as
negative like you go there you know you
go with oh he hating on me or she hating
on me I'll give you a prime example when
I was average I saw my wife's treatment
of my gift as opposition like yeah oh
she and supported me you know I'm saying
like Oh am I here speaking you know I'm
saying like every time I speak she
critiquing me you know she never said
none positive about my presentation like
every time I get offstage if it's the
best that I thought I ever did she like
what you should have done this you
shouldn't have said that like come on
you know better than that you didn't I'm
just like yo what's up like where's the
support you know that was average you
know great was she going to work when
I'm working on becoming a motivational
speaker I go to work every day so she
supported you
you got health insurance because she had
health insurance
she had a 401k she's built up a bank
account
she got a phenomenal credit score and
got us a house with her credit score you
guys gonna say no but when I was average
it was like you're not doing what I want
you to do but when I became great I
realized you know I already got 40
people that just said that was a
phenomenal message you don't get better
by people telling you what you did right
you get better by watching the film you
get better by critiquing yourself so
here's a person who's brave enough to
critique me because somebody else might
have thought the same thing but they
wasn't gonna say none to me about it you
know I'm saying so just looking at the
situation like you know don't look at it
average people look at you know what it
is they don't critical think they don't
analyze they don't they don't they don't
unpack you know what I'm saying like
they just see that's blue and not go
deeper into well actually that could be
ever it is yellow and purple whatever
colors make blue light this is what this
really is so for me
average taking everything as it was
you know victim phenomenal Victoire and
seeing possibilities seeing beyond you
know what surf is that to me that's one
of the characteristics that determine a
person who's average versus somebody
who's great raise your standard Apple at
the core its core value is that people
passion not one drop of myself work
depends on Europe it's something serene
if you liked this video want to learn
how you can be the next Elon Musk check
out the video I made on that topic the
link is right there next to me I think
you'll enjoy it continue to believe and
I'll see you there
I could drop below a certain threshold
of sleep and although I'd be awake more
hours and I could sustain it I would get
less done because mental acuity would be
affected